okay so we're laying out a case that's
what we do here on the reuben report
program and as you can see some good
things are happening elon's fighting
netflix is coming around hulu is coming
around the culture the culture war
is starting to move in our favor
and politics is downstream from culture
so there's big things on the horizon so
jeff bezos now jeff bezos i get it some
people like them some people don't
we all use amazon i try to use it less i
try to shop locally when i can but we
get it there's the convenience of the
app and stuff shows up to your door next
day or even same day sometimes
so he created this incredible
marketplace of amazon right he created
this thing where you could do crafts at
home and put it on the amazon
marketplace and they take a big cut of
it and sometimes then they create the
same product and put you out of business
but they give you a chance amazon okay
it is ubiquitous in society okay amazon
aws that basically runs the entire
internet although rumble we're coming
for you um but he also is a guy who has
bought the washington post and the
washington post is a democrat paper it
is leftist propaganda and all that so
i'm not telling you that the guy is
jesus i'm just telling you that he's a
powerful influential guy and when they
start coming around that means some good
things are happening so here is a tweet
from joe biden he is the elderly man
pretending to be president and this is
what joe biden said he said you want to
bring down inflation let's make sure the
wealthiest corporations pay their fair
share now
before i show you jeff bezos's response
to this i would just like to add my
opinion on this which is of course as
you know that's a completely nonsensical
thing his argument is if we only just
took more money from corporations that
we wouldn't have inflation that our debt
wouldn't be so high all of this nonsense
it's completely insane this is the same
guy who's just printing money by the way
while i was gone uh congress authorized
40 million for ukraine
i'm sure we'd have no better use for
that right
so they just print money endlessly and
then they blame the productive people
they blame the the tech people they
bring blame the corporate people people
who are making things uh for all of our
problems so jeff bezos saw this tweet
and he responded with this he said the
newly created disinformation board
should review this tweet or maybe they
need to form a new non-sequitur board
instead raising corporate taxes is fine
to discuss taming inflation is critical
to discuss mushing them together is just
misdirection now i don't know that
raising corporate taxes is going to do
anything the idea that if we just took
money from corporations and i'm not
saying all corporations are good i'm not
saying greed doesn't exist but the idea
that you just took more money if the
government just took more money from
corporations or people so it had more
money that it would do more good i just
think there's no evidence for that but
bezos was trying to be nice there right
he's trying to be magnanimous he's
trying to say okay we can maybe discuss
that but he's saying his point is this
has nothing to do with inflation
inflation has everything to do with
printing money relentlessly inflation
has everything to do with all of the big
government programs that you morons
are constantly pushing and i also like
the fact that he poked at their
disinformation board right the
disinformation board which has been
suspended now which is a beautiful thing
so this is more winning right so the
corporations are turning against this
thing the disinformation board went away
the masks got taken off because of one
35 year old judge in tampa about six
weeks ago uh the dems are losing they
are they are losing right in front of
our faces they're losing the cultural
institutions and when you lose the
cultural institutions you start losing
the political war